oh
it's gotta be me you sought those stones
that the thanos
they almost killed them
none of you could survive how do we know
you will
we don't but the radiation's mostly
gamma
it's like
i was made for this
good to go yeah
let's do it okay remember everyone
thanos snapped away five years ago
just bringing them back to now today
don't change anything from the last five
years
good
[Music]
everybody comes home
[Applause]
[Music]
talk to me banner
okay i'm okay
bruce don't move
hi everybody it's charlie surprise
surprise the producers and the writers
of avengers endgame
revealed a big red hulk scene that
didn't make it into the final cut of the
movie so we'll break it down
there's a new round of that avengers
endgame blu-ray giveaway too all you
have to do to enter is be a subscriber
and leave your biggest marvel phase 4
theory on the video i'll name a new
winner at the end of this everybody's
been asking about red hulk ever since we
got avengers infinity war are we gonna
see thunderbolt ross ever become
red hulk well the red hulk scene that
the producers and the writers told us
about
is very different from people's
expectations
it would have been very different from
red hulk in the comics and the reason
why it didn't make it into the movie is
very similar to the reason why they
caught the grey hulk scene out of
avengers age of ultron which i'll
explain if you guys don't know the grey
hulk story it's also pretty fascinating
but during avengers end game what was
originally going to happen in this scene
here that i put at the beginning of the
video where hulk is wielding the
infinity gauntlet
is that when iron man assembles his nano
infinity gauntlet which is the official
name that marvel is giving it the nano
gauntlet
because it's made with iron man's nano
technology what happens is that hulk
detects the intense cosmic energy
and gamma radiation coming off of the
combined infinity stones
and thinks that it's similar to the
gamma that irradiated him
giving him his hulk powers originally so
when he puts the infinity gauntlet on in
the theatrical cut you can see the same
thing happening to him that happened to
thanos when thanos put the mind stone in
the gauntlet and combined all
six you see that giant arc of cosmic and
gamma energy arcing across their bodies
and the reason they can soak that damage
is because they're so powerful
like when thanos added one stone at a
time you see
one arc of cosmic and gamma energy run
up his body
when he added the second stone you see
two arcs go up and so on and so forth
the energy starts to stack so it's not
like you have six times
that energy running up you it grows
exponentially so that's why it kills
normal humans that haven't been enhanced
like captain america
the reason why captain america is a lot
of people wonder didn't wear the
infinity gauntlet is because hulk was
standing there and he's way more
powerful
so if hulk hadn't been there if it had
just been captain american iron man then
it would have been captain america to
wield the gauntlet and snap everyone
back
but what happened in the original
version of this scene where hulk is
snapping everyone back
is that when he put the infinity
gauntlet on the combined gamma and
cosmic energy from the gauntlet
interacted with his
own gamma energy in the catalytic
reaction turned him
into red hulk instead of just destroying
his arm
the main reason why the writers revealed
that that didn't make it into the final
cut of the films because
one it was really confusing it was a big
change to the comics and everybody kind
of been asking for red hulk at some
point
because thunderbolt ross is still alive
even though he had been snapped in that
five-year time jump that's why you never
saw him at the beginning of the movie he
only appears at the funeral at the end
because he'd been snapped
during that big five year time jump
that's kind of the reason why they
didn't do grey hulk
during avengers age of ultron the story
that joss whedon told about grey hulk
because obviously the grey hulk in the
comics is joe fix it
and is very different from what joss
whedon was talking about when he was
talking about his gray hulk scene
what was supposed to happen is that
scarlet witch when she messes with his
mind and he hulks out she messes with
him so much that he's supposed to go
world breaker hulk mad the way joss
whedon talked about it is that what
happens if the hulk were already the
hulk
and then hulks out on top of that what's
the hulk's version of the hulk
when they were editing this big fight
scene with iron man he had the visual
effects artist
push his color crazier and crazier but
what happened is
that he started to look gray so josh
whedon is like oh okay this is starting
to turn into a gray hulk
scene so after a while he just decided
that it got too confusing for test
audiences
they would have needed to have a whole
separate scene explaining who
this different color this different
version of the hulk is so that's why he
pulled way back on it effectively
getting rid of the gray hulk stuff
during the movie and then went to kevin
feige while they were still working on
the film and said here's a big twist a
grey hulk twist that you can always use
in a future movie if you want
so it's basically the same situation
with red hulk in the marvel cinematic
universe a big twist that they can
always use in marvel phase 4 or marvel
phase 5 if they want to
because mark ruffalo is still around
they still have that big deal with
universal that's making it hard for them
to release a solo hulk film so there
will still be hulk stuff going on during
marvel phase 4 marvel phase 5 but there
are a couple big twists that they
haven't used yet
but they haven't made any promise that
it would be the thunderbolt ross version
of red hulk there's just an idea that a
red hulk might pop up at some point
if you're not familiar with where the
red hulk in the comics came from it's
actually
right out of world war hulk i know
everybody wants world breaker hulk
within the marvel cinematic universe
when are we gonna get world breaker hulk
the funny thing is is the comic book
world breaker hulk was used to create
comic book red hulk so during world war
hulk
hook goes full world breaker turns on
all his former friends
iron man and the other heroes developed
a last-ditch way
to de-power him using earth's satellites
getting rid of all this cosmic and gamma
energy that was inside of him
while this was going on the
intelligentsia which is modoc and a
bunch of the other smartest villains in
the marvel comic book universe
got together and developed a way to hack
iron man's special
technology that he was going to use on
the hulk they knew that they needed a
weapon that they could control
that could fight people like the hulk
and the other heroes they knew it was
just going to be a matter of time
before they came back for them to stop
them from trying to take over the world
so in the middle of world war hulk while
hulk is fighting the century to a
standstill
iron man activates his anti-hulk weapon
protocol
and because it's happening in such a
panic he doesn't have time to double
check the math
or make sure that everything's working
correctly he just fires the weapon off
the weapon is meant to de-power him back
into banner form so that they can
actually deal with them
but while this is happening modoc who
has hacked this technology
siphons off all that cosmic and gamma
energy and puts it into another person
creating the red hulk that person just
happened to be the resurrected
body of thunderbolt ross who was working
with the intelligentsia so when he
started out in the comics red hulk was
this big villain he was a big [ __ ]
that everybody wanted to get rid of
eventually he regains his sanity and
turns into more of an anti-hero working
with some of the more morally grey
superheroes he goes on a bunch of cosmic
adventures he does a bunch of crazy
things
just recently because of absolute
carnage if you guys haven't been reading
that story arc
they just killed the character off
carnage came for him because at one time
he had a symbiote that's a whole
different story because they're getting
ready to start shooting the venom sequel
the venom versus carnage movie
i will talk about more venom and carnage
absolute carnage stuff if it's relevant
to what's going on during the movie but
leave all your video requests in the
comments below and let me know in the
comments
if they do red hulk because william hurt
is getting up there in years if he's not
able to come back and
play the actual red hulk in like five or
six years what would you want them to do
with that character
because i know everybody wants to see
him at some point we're all waiting on
she-hulk amadeus cho
pretty much any other version of the
hulk you could think of because i mean
obviously they're going to keep making
marvel movies till the heat death of the
universe so at some point we will see
these characters and i'm sure eventually
marvel will find a way to get the rest
of the rights back from universal
so that they can do another hulk solo
film at some point but that might not
happen until way down the road after
mark ruffalo isn't playing the character
anymore so really speculation that would
just wind up being a different version
of that character but
motion capture technology is getting so
perfect that mark ruffalo could probably
play the hulk for another 10 years
without any big problems
i'm working on spider-man far from home
deleted scenes that video should post
pretty soon congratulations to the
giveaway winner from my last big marvel
video cinema dog 02 please email me on
the about page of my channel so i can
get your details
everybody click here for my venom 2
teaser video venom vs carnage and click
here for my video about amazon's
the boys series basically dark justice
league thank you so much for watching
everybody stay awesome i'll see you guys
[Music]
tonight